Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and so much went
down on Arrow this week that I’m going to
add a few bonus moments to my top 5 list.
But we have a lot we need to talk about.
And in case you didn’t know there are only
three more episode left this season.
I was going to post a bonus video this morning
but I had some technical issues and now I’m
just posting it in a few hours.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll also have a link to it in the description.
So careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet, but let’s start with top
5 moments.
Number 5 - Roy Flips His Shit On Everyone
Did anyone else get a Frankenstein vibe with
him lying there on the table?
They could have done this episode during Halloween
and it would have been appropriate.
I knew that he’d hallucinate Thea, but I
was surprised that she told him to kill her.
Slade’s Shado hallucination seems a little
more insidious, but I guess it just depends
on what your mind is like before you get injected
with mirakuru.
In case you don’t remember back to Heir
to the Demon, episode 13, they’ve got him
on an IV Drip of the Pit Viper Venom Nyssa
Al Ghul was using.
It’s supposed to be enough to take down
an elephant.
So until the cure is ready, they’re going
to keep Roy in a medically induced coma.
In real life that’s really common for patients
who are at risk for injuring themselves really
badly.
My big surprise in all this was mostly that
Sin seems to not be in on any of the Team
Arrow stuff.
I thought she was like Sara’s partner in
crime, but I guess she’s more like a sister,
like Laurel.
Number 4 - Sara Breaks Up With Oliver and
Takes Off
Biggest question was who is that old friend.
My first guess is that it’s Slade, but I
think based on what happened later in the
episode, she’s going back to the League
of Assassin’s.
I’m expecting them to come back to Starling
City before the finale and run clean up on
some of Slade’s mirakuru soldiers.
So maybe that’s what Sara’s comeback moment
will be.
She’ll come back in the darkest hour.
I got really worried when she started all
that darkness inside me talk, as if the writers
were laying groundwork for her eventual death.
But there had been so many other clues that
she’d live, especially all the Birds of
Prey talk.
It took the rest of the episode to figure
it all out.
High Fives to the writers for pulling a bit
of a misdirect with that last big scene.
Right now we only have episode descriptions
up to the finale.
So it doesn’t look like Sara will be back
until Episode 23.
Hopefully she’ll bring Ra’s Al Ghul with
her.
Number 3 - Oliver Is Out Of Commission
His leg is pretty f’d up which is why he
pretty much jumped into Felicity’s arms
at the bottom of the stairs.
Who else got a flashback to last season when
he carried her in his arms.
It was a nice funny moment in an otherwise
shocking episode.
Felicity as always had the best jokes in the
episode.
Can you even fit into those leather pants?
And she made fun of him for being too heavy.
Who else laughed out loud when Oliver was
like where are the drugs, I need all of the
drugs.
And just downed everything.
I think it was barely enough to keep him standing
without crying while they subdued Roy.
I kept getting the feeling that the writers
wanted us to wonder whether or not Oliver
would take the Mirakuru.
He can’t, they can’t synthesize anymore,
and the last sample is being used by Caitlin
Snow to make the cure at Star Labs in Central
City.
Number 2 - Oliver has a Child
I didn’t see the name of that woman, so
if they wrote it in the credits please add
it in the comments below.
But we should assume his child is still alive
and in Central City.
They were fuzzy on how far back that flashback
went, but I’d guess the boy or girl would
be between 6 and 7 years old.
Old enough for a young actor to be cast with
speaking lines.
Remember Slade said that one other person
had to die.
I think that in the finale “Unthinkable”
Slade will magic up Oliver’s child and threaten
their life.
I’m avoiding pronouns, but I think we’re
all expecting a Connor Hawke situation.
That’s such a huge place for the story to
go in season 3, I totally think that said
child will survive and be a part of what happens
going forward.
Him living in Central City is just another
perfect opportunity to link Arrow and Flash
stories.
Now Oliver has a reason to quote unquote visit
Barry’s city.
Let me know if you agree.
and my Number 1 moment - Slade kills Moira
Queen
Huge WTF, but there were some parts of this
that I expected and a few things about it
that really surprised me.
First, in my finale predictions video I did
last week, I predicted Moira would die.
But I didn’t think she would die this way.
I expected Slade to use Felicity, Sara and
Felicity, or Thea or really any of the other
women except for Moira.
Remember, she never told Oliver about his
son and she didn’t have time to tell them
Merlyn is still alive.
So they have a few surprises in store.
I think they did a really good job of sending
the character off, they gave her that very
dignified moment at the end where she chose
her children over her own life.
And Slade even called her out on it and gave
her respect.
I think that’s why he used the blade instead
of shooting her in the head.
I really love that she and Oliver had that
other moment earlier where she let him know
she knew about the Arrow and they reconciled.
So before we talk about repercussions from
all this let me know what your favorite moment
was.
The Connor Hawke teaser, Moira dying or something
else?
The thing that’s really sticking with me
right now is Slade’s line, “There’s
still one more person that has to die.”
So let’s talk about what all this means
for the final episodes.
First off, next week we saw in the teaser:
The funeral, Oliver can’t be found, Slade
unleashes his army, including Ravager and
Brother Blood has his big moment.
So things are going to get worse before they
get better, but like I said.
I expect Oliver’s Child to be a plot point
before the end of the season, Sara will be
back with the League of Assassins and Merlyn
is also coming back.
We’re not really sure what he’s going
to do.
He could either just take Thea away or help
them out.
Overall I gave the episode a solid A. They
keep making things worse and worse for Oliver
and Team Arrow and it’s only going to make
their victory that much sweeter.
More than any other show this year with the
exception of Game of Thrones, I think Arrow
has surprised me the most with how much fun
it’s been to analyze week to week.
It’s a big tribute to the writers that what
they and the cast and crew have done lends
itself to heavy analysis and discussion.
The only thing I’m still waiting for is
Thea to either pick up a bow and head down
Oliver’s path or follow Laurel and become
just a more self-actualized stealth member
of the team.
I was happy to see Sin again, I think she’ll
be around for the finale.
I’m hoping she and Roy get to have some
more Young Justice moments next season where
they go off on missions by themselves.
That’s another thing I’ll talk about more
when the finale is over.
Them doing more odd pairings of characters
in season 3.
Like for instance, Diggle and Thea had a scene
together and we haven’t really seen them
get a moment like that in a long long time.
It was really good.
Let me know in the comments which characters
you want to see have scenes together that
normally wouldn't’t.
Like Quentyn and Diggle at a bar telling stories.
Like I said, I’ll post that bonus video
in a couple hours.
It’s my Top 10 Team Arrow moments this season.
Moments when it’s just the team.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
And leave me suggestions for future bonus
videos.
Right now you can click here for that video.
I’ll update the link as soon as I post it.
And you can click here for my Q&A video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!